- It's not that difficult
to be a young CEO.
Some people mistake me as an adult.
People are generally supportive
about what I'm doing,
and I get a lot of pretty
interesting advice from people.
- [Narrator] This Great Big
Story was made possible by LEGO.
Play her way.
- I'm Hillary Yip, I'm 14
and I live in Hong Kong.
I'm the founder and CEO of MinorMynas.
Minor Mynas started as a
foreign language learning app,
where we connect kids
from all over the world.
First to learn in a
peer-to-peer environment
and to make friends from across boarders.
Right now we've got users from
150 countries and counting.
I think we kids are
neglected on the market
before other video games
or educational products.
MinorMynas wants to be the middle ground,
where we're able to have
fun by getting to connect
with new friends, while being
able to learn something new.
When I was 10 years old
my Chinese was appalling,
and my mom finally had it
and sent my brother and I to
a Chinese summer camp.
It went very well because we had no choice
but to speak in Mandarin.
And a couple months later when I saw
entrepreneurship competition for kids,
I wondered if I could bring
the experience online,
so that all us kids can learn languages
in a more effective manner.
After the competition,
someone approached me
and said that he'd love to be my mentor
if I wanted to continue my idea.
So I jumped at the chance.
What is MinorMynas able to do?
First of all, we are able to provide
a safe environment for kids.
The best thing about
being a CEO is the freedom
and the flexibility.
What I do on a day-to-day basis
is generally pitching,
developing investor decks,
talking to investors,
talking to customers,
writing up our vision for the future
and executing upon marketing grounds.
Outside of school hours, I tend to just
prioritize my tasks with MinorMynas.
So, after I get every thing done,
I get to read, I get to debate,
and when my friends are in town
I get to hangout with them.
My family has been very very supportive.
(mumbles) my mom learning with me
throughout the whole
journey of MinorMynas.
Because none of us have
worked on a startup before.
There will always be people
who tell you that you can't.
Whether it's because of your
age, gender, where your from.
But what we can do is
to continue working on
what we're doing.
That's the only way we
can prove them wrong.